مرحباً، أهلاً وسهلاً بالجميع. كيف حالكم جميعاً اليوم؟ سيكون هذا درساً
رائعاً في الاستماع والتحدث. أنا سعيدٌ جداً بحضوركم جميعاً. أهلاً
وسهلاً بالجميع. أترون الشاشة؟ حسناً. الآن؟ نعم. حسناً. إذاً تذكروا، التواصل
الجيد يبدأ بالاستماع الجيد، أن تكون مستمعاً فعالاً يعني أن تُظهر
أنك منخرطٌ ومشارك. أحياناً نستمع بسرعةٍ للفكرة الرئيسية وهذا هو تفكيرنا
السريع والحدسي، وفي أحيانٍ أخرى نحتاج إلى استماعٍ تحليليٍّ
دقيق، وذلك عندما نقوم حقاً بتفكيك الأمور ونحاول
فهم المعنى الأعمق لتلك الأشياء. لذا نحتاج إلى ممارسة كلا النوعين
من الاستماع لفهم المستوى السطحي للأشياء في معناها
ولفهم المستوى التحليلي الأعمق للأشياء. عندما تتدربون كثيراً،
ستألفون الأمر ولن تضطروا إلى السعي عمداً لفهمه
إلى هذا الحد. ستفهمون ببساطة وسيصبح الأمر أكثر حدسية مع الوقت، ولكن
من الجيد دائماً التحليل أولاً. إذاً سنستمع بينما يُقرأ السيناريو
هنا. أريدكم أن تستمعوا إليه مرتين بتركيزٍ مختلف، وأنا أحاول
أن أعرض شيئاً قد لا تفهمونه. لذا لا تشعروا بالسوء إذا لم تفعلوا. حسناً.
حسناً. حسناً يا فريق. بالنسبة للمشروع الجديد، أحتاج من الجميع أن يوحدوا جهودهم (synergize)
في تسليماتهم (deliverables) بحلول نهاية دوام (COB) يوم الثلاثاء وأن يضمنوا مشاركة استباقية من أصحاب المصلحة.
أنجزوا الأمر بسرعة (Make it snappy). هل فهمتم؟ الفكرة الرئيسية، ولكن هناك بعض الكلمات الجديدة.
الأخرى لا بأس بها. حسناً، إذاً لديك بعض الخبرة وهذا رائع. لقد فهمت
الفكرة الرئيسية وهي أننا بحاجة للعمل معاً لإنجاز شيء ما، ولكن قد يكون
هناك بعض الأشياء هنا التي لا تفهمها. ما هي الكلمات التي تجد صعوبة في فهمها؟
الكلمات التي لا أفهمها هي
"synergize" و "snappy". حسناً، إذاً "synergize" لشيء ما يعني بشكل أساسي جعل الأشياء
متزامنة (in sync)، أليس كذلك؟ عندما تكون الأشياء متزامنة، تكون "synergized" (متآزرة/متضافرة). إنها
تعمل معاً بشكل جيد، أليس كذلك؟ لذا نحتاج من الجميع بشكل أساسي أن يجتمعوا
ويتفقوا على التسليمات، أي ما يجب إنتاجه بحلول يوم الثلاثاء، و "make it snappy"
تعني أن تفعله بسرعة. أوه، حسناً. عندما تتحدث،
أنت تستخدم تلك الكلمة، أليس كذلك؟ أوه، "أنجز الأمر بسرعة" (make it snappy).
حسناً. إذاً دعونا نستمع إلى سيناريو قصير ونتخيل أنكم في هذا
الاجتماع. إذا سمعتم ذلك في اجتماع، ماذا كنتم
ستفعلون للمقاطعة ومحاولة الفهم؟ إذا كان لديكم نوع من الأسئلة، لقد فهمتم الفكرة الرئيسية، أليس كذلك؟
ولكنكم ربما سترغبون في الاستماع إلى ما سيأتي بعد ذلك قليلاً.
كيف ستطلبون توضيحاً؟
حسناً، كما ذكرتَ، كل شيء يتعلق بالاستماع. لذا أعتقد أنني سأنتظر الشخص
حتى ينهي ما (سيقوله)؟ وإذا لم أفهم، عندها سأذهب
وأقول، اسمح لي، أحتاج إلى توضيح بشأن هذا الجزء مما قلته للتو.
إذاً ستنتظر حتى ينهي الشخص قول ما يريد قوله.* وهذا لأنك
لا تريد أن تكون وقحاً أو تقاطع أي شخص أثناء حديثه. نعم. في الواقع، أنا دائماً
أحاول الانتظار لأنك تحتاج إلى معرفة ما يفكر فيه الشخص وليس مجرد الاعتقاد بأن
هذا ما تقوله. نعم، من الجيد عدم وضع افتراضات. أتفق معك. ومن الرائع الانتظار
لتلك الوقفات في الكلام والمحادثة لمعرفة متى يمكننا طلب توضيح.
حسناً. إذاً كيف نقاطع بأدب؟ هذا جزء مما نتحدث عنه اليوم.
طلب التوضيح. هناك عبارات مفيدة. حسناً، سأقول، عفواً،
ماذا يعني، سيكون ذلك مثالاً جيداً.
لذا سأقول، عفواً، أود فقط أن أعرف ماذا تقصد عندما تتحدث
عن هذا العقد أو شيء من هذا القبيل. حسناً. لذا أحتاج إلى مزيد من التوضيح حول هذه الموضوعات.
حسناً. هذا رسمي جداً. يعجبني ذلك.
نعم، نحن بحاجة إلى... هذا يشبه بيئتنا عندما نتحدث في اجتماعاتنا.
يمكننا المزاح* في الخارج، كما تعلم، ولكن عندما نكون في الاجتماع، نحتاج إلى محاولة أن نكون
محترفين حقاً. يمكنك أن تكون أكثر عفوية خارج الاجتماع، ولكن في الاجتماع
نفسه، حان الوقت لتكون محترفاً ورسمياً. حسناً. إذاً هذا السجل اللغوي حقاً
رسمي بعض الشيء وكذلك التنغيم مهم. كما تعلم، الأصوات ترتفع وتنخفض أيضاً. لذا
مثال على ذلك هو، آسف. هل يمكنك من فضلك تكرار الجزء المتعلق بـ COB؟ أو هل يمكنك تكرار الجزء
المتعلق بـ "أنجز الأمر بسرعة" (making it snappy)؟ ماذا يعني ذلك؟ حسناً. الآن لاحظوا أننا استخدمنا "could" هنا و "could"
تعتبر أكثر أدباً من "can". لذا "could" أكثر رسمية قليلاً ثم "can" أكثر
عفوية قليلاً، على الرغم من أنه يمكنك استخدام أي منهما. لا يعتبر الشخص غير محترم إذا استخدم "can"،
ولكن إذا كنت تريد إظهار المزيد من الرسمية، فمن الأفضل استخدام "could". إليكم مثال آخر.
هذه المرة أود منكم محاولة رفع التنغيم في النهاية. مثلاً، "هل هذا صحيح؟" (Is that right?)
حسناً. "هل هذا صحيح؟" هل يمكنك، هل يمكنك قراءة هذا الجزء هنا؟
إذا فهمت بشكل صحيح، فأنت تطلب منا أن...، هل هذا صحيح؟
هل هذا صحيح؟ نعم. وإليكم مثال آخر. نحن نعمل كثيراً. هل هذا صحيح؟
يجب أن نأتي في نهاية هذا الأسبوع. هل هذا صحيح؟ حسناً. ماذا عن هذا؟ هل يمكنك أن تقرأ
هذا لنا؟ هل يمكنك من فضلك أن تشرح ماذا تقصد بـ "snappy"؟
أهأ. جيد جداً. مرحباً، "snappy". حسناً، "snappy" تعني أن يكون سريعاً وحيوياً.
حسناً، لا، أعتقد أن هذا جيد. يمكننا استخدام، على سبيل المثال، مثل الذي قلته COB لأن
هناك بعض الأشخاص* الذين لا يعرفون ماذا تعني COB. يمكنك ببساطة أن تسأل، هل يمكنك
أن تخبرني ماذا تعني "snappy"؟ أنا لا أعرف هذا. إنها كلمة جديدة بالنسبة لي، يمكنك القول.
كما تعلمون، أعتقد أننا أحياناً نشعر بالحرج عندما لا نعرف شيئاً ما.
لذا لا نريد أن نسأل، لا نريد أن نعترف، ولكن لا بأس في طلب التوضيح.
الغرض الكامل من التواصل والأعمال هو أن تَفهَم وأن تُفهَم.
والنقطة الرئيسية من هذه الشريحة هنا هي أننا بشكل أساسي نستخدم "could" لتقديم طلبات مهذبة.
يمكنك استخدام علامات الخطاب مثل "Excuse me" أو "If I understand correctly, you're asking..." أو "you're telling us that's right"
ثم إعادة صياغة ما يقولونه. هذه طرق رائعة حقاً
لطلب التوضيح. حسناً. إذاً تفضل، أنا آسف.
لا، ربما في السابق لم أكن أفعل ذلك، ولكن الآن أشعر بثقة أكبر في السؤال عن معنى الكلمة،
لمعرفة ما يقولونه. لذا نعرف بالضبط ما يحاولون إيصاله.
نعم... الأمر يتحسن مع الوقت فقط.